now that we've spent a good amount of
time testing our new high-end
2025k imac it's time to start comparing
it to our other machines
like our older high-end 2017 and 2019
imacs
our 15 000 mac pro and of course my base
5 000
imac pro that i've been using daily for
a year now and that's what this video is
all about now i know a lot of you guys
are waiting to see how our lower end
i7 8 core 2020 imac compares to this
high end 10 core model
and we're actually working on that video
right now so subscribe if you want to
see those comparison videos
but before we get into comparing the
high-end imac to the imac pro
i want to show you guys our brand new
premium max tech
zip up hoodie which comes with a small
and subtle logo on the
front and the same apple product pattern
that we get on our mask
on the back of the hoodie with various
icons like the mac pro
the imac the apple watch and the new
ipad pro
so definitely check it out in our merch
shelf right below this video i'll get
into the real world performance
differences for things like logic pro 10
photo editing and video editing in just
a minute but first let's compare the
differences
in the design the ports the speakers and
the microphones
there are three main differences in
design number one is that the imac pro
gets the exclusive
space gray color which also comes on the
mouse and the larger keyboard
which comes with a numpad unlike the one
that comes with the 5k
imac number two is that the 2020 imac
gets a 500
option for the nano textured glass which
basically gives you a glare free display
without sacrificing the contrast and
color quality
like other matte display films do but we
didn't pay for this upgrade because we
don't think it's worth the 500
price and number three is the fact that
the imac pro sacrifices the user
replaceable ram door
in order to have an upgraded cooling
system with dual fans
larger heat sinks and extra exhaust
vents on the back the imac has finally
been upgraded with a 1080p webcam
just like the one on the imac pro so
here's a quick comparison of the
microphone and webcam quality
this is the new 1080p webcam on the 2020
5k imac and this is the 1080p webcam on
the 2017 imac pro as you just saw
there's not that big of a difference in
terms of the webcam
so now let's compare the speakers
[Music]
is
[Music]
hello
let me know if you heard any noticeable
differences between both machines down
in the comment section below
and now let's get into comparing the
ports both of them get four
usb a ports which are running at a
maximum speed of 5 gigabits per second
as you can see right here in the
screenshots and what's great this year
for the imac is that it supports uh s2
transfer speeds with the sd card reader
just like the one that comes on
the imac pro the 5k imac now finally has
an available
100 upgrade option to get a very fast
10 gigabit ethernet port just like the
imac pro comes with
which is great for using nas servers and
apart from that
the imac pro comes with 4 thunderbolt 3
ports
instead of just 2 on the 5k imac so with
that out of the way
let's finally get into performance but
first i want to show you guys the
differences
in the specs and i want to mention that
my imac pro
is an 8 core model but if you're buying
one new right now
the base model now comes with a 10 core
so keep that in mind
and you'll also notice that because the
5k imac has a ram door
we bought 64 gigs of ram for only 240
on amazon and upgraded it ourselves
giving it an
advantage over the imac pro which
actually has a larger ssd
at the base price but either way the 5k
imac
is significantly cheaper and with that
let's get right into our performance
comparison
starting with a fan noise test which we
ran by using a terminal script
that maxes out the cpu and the fan noise
you're about to hear
is after exactly five minutes of running
the script on each mac
so let me know what you think about the
fan noise differences down in the
comments below
and now let's finally get into the
benchmarks starting with geekbench 5
cpu test in terms of single core
performance
the imac kills the imac pro so if you're
doing tasks that only use
one core there's going to be a huge
advantage for the regular imac
and in terms of multi-core score we see
basically the same results
with over 20 percent more raw multi-core
performance
using the 10 core cpu on the new imac
now running the cinebench r20 cpu stress
test
the 5k imac somehow scored 50 higher
than the imac pro which is super
impressive now let's get into graphics
performance
starting with geekbench 5's metal test
and here
the imax 5700 xt outperformed the imac
pros vega 56
by just a little bit we then tested
unigine's heaven gaming benchmark on the
extreme preset
and the imac scored around 22 more fps
than the imac pro which is definitely
more along the lines of what we were
expecting
and we actually played some games on
windows 10 using bootcamp and it
performed
very well so definitely check out our
gaming review after this video
now since unigine heaven uses opengl we
also ran some metal benchmarks
using gfx bench 5.0 in the aztec ruins
test
the 5k imac scored around 25 more fps
than the imac pro and in the manhattan
test there was a smaller
difference since we were already close
to reaching 400 fps in that test
now one thing i do want to mention
before we move on is that the 5700 xt in
the imac
comes with 16 gigs of vram compared to 8
gigs with
the vega 56 on the imac pro
but the bandwidth on the imac pro is
actually a little bit higher
with 400 gigabytes per second of
bandwidth now before we finally get into
our video editing tests with final cut
pro 10
let's test everything from photo editing
logic pro 10 music production
and xcode programming we ran the puget
bench photoshop benchmark
and the 5k imac actually scored around
35 percent higher
than the imac pro which is pretty
surprising and we think the difference
is due to the extra cores
and the extra ram we then exported 500
raw
42 megapixel photos in lightroom classic
and we saw the complete opposite result
the imac pro
actually finished 5 minutes faster than
the 5k imac
even though it was 35 slower in puget
bench for photoshop
and then we created 50 raw one-to-one
previews
and the imac pro was 16 seconds faster
in this test as well
so it's definitely a better choice but
this result just doesn't make sense
considering the raw performance
difference we did a little bit of
digging and we realized that the imac
pro is
actually using 4 channel memory compared
to only dual channel on
the imac which is allowing it to perform
better
even though it has two times less
physical ram now moving on to the max
tech
xcode benchmark created for us by max
aramenko
which you can find a link to in the
description the 5k imac was a little
over
20 faster than the imac pro thanks to
the extra cpu performance
now getting into music production we ran
the new logic pro 10 benchmark 2
which tests how many tracks the system
can handle without getting an
overload error message and surprisingly
the imac pro was able to play 31 more
tracks
than the 5k imac before overloading the
reason for that is because the imac pro
uses
server grade xeon chips that are more
reliable
and run at more stable clock speeds but
if you're not trying to max out the
system with tons of tracks
the 5k imac should perform just as well
for day-to-day music production
and now finally getting into final cut
pro 10 the imac was surprisingly over 50
faster in the bruce x 5k benchmark
which we think is due to the differences
in raw performance
and the new navi based graphics
architecture in the 5700 xt
then moving on to our 1 minute 4k hevc
stabilization test
the 5k imac destroyed the imac pro
by finishing four times faster which
didn't make any sense
but then we dug deeper and realized that
the 5k imac is using
quick sync to encode which the imac pro
doesn't have
because it lacks an integrated graphics
chip now onto our 5 minute 4k
h.264 export test which is basically the
most common format that youtubers use
the 5k imac was just 3 seconds faster
than the imac pro
so it's not that big of a difference so
because of that
this year we're adding a brand new h.264
test
exporting one of our very own videos
which is 12 minutes long
and packs a bunch of effects and graphs
that we use
all the time in our videos so it's just
about the most
real world test you can get here the 5k
imac shows its true colors
finishing the export almost a minute and
a half quicker
than the imac pro so for regular 4k
h.264 editing
the imac is definitely the better choice
and for a lower price
now what about hevc editing which is
quickly becoming the new
standard well in our five minute export
test
the 5k imac was just 3 seconds faster
since both machines are limited by the
encoding speed of the t2 chip
which handles hevc footage and i do want
to mention that the navi graphics card
in the imac
actually has new hevc encoders that run
at 90 frames per second compared to the
t2 chips
60 fps but final cut hasn't yet been
updated to support these new navi
encoders
but when it eventually does in the
future the 5k imac should get even
faster for hevc editing now a lot of you
guys have been asking us to edit canon's
422
eos r5 footage and it actually improved
with the new final cut pro 10.4.9 update
so if you want more info on that max
actually made a video on his other
channel focusing on that new codec
so i'll link to that video in the end
screen after this one's over
but i did run a transcoding test on a 30
minute canon r5 clip
and the 5k imac finished the transcode
quite a bit faster
than the imac pro so there's that now
moving on to canon c200 raw footage
the new final cut pro update broke it so
we're currently waiting on canon to
release the new raw plug-in so we ran
our
minute export test using the previous
version of final cut pro
and the 5k imac finished over three
minutes faster
than the imac pro and in terms of the
playback fps in the timeline
both of them played the footage at a
perfect 60 60fps
which is very impressive now moving on
to redraw editing
we ran the new version of final cut pro
with the new raw plug-in
and the 5k imac easily killed the imac
pro
finishing our 5-minute 4.5 k export in
exactly 5 minutes
and then moving on to the 8k redraw test
the 5k imac finished a very impressive
4 minutes faster than the imac pro and
the new final cut pro update helps a
huge amount
since it used to take over 17 minutes
using the previous 10.4.8 version
of final cut and in terms of playing
back this ak footage
the 5k imac can run it at around 19 fps
out of 24
while the imac pro runs it at around 15
fps
so there you guys go from all of these
tests that we ran
we can conclude that the 5k imac is
better for
almost everything including video
editing
programming with xcode graphic design
with photoshop
and gaming as well but the imac pro
actually performed better
for lightroom classic photo editing
thanks to the quad channel ram
and it handled more tracks in logic pro
10
thanks to the more stable server grade
xeon chip and thankfully
the port situation has been improved
with the 5k imac
now that it finally has a faster sd card
slot and an option for a 10 gig ethernet
port
but the imac pro still has the advantage
of two extra thunderbolt 3 ports
so with all that said if we're looking
at the entire system in general
the 5k imac is obviously the better
choice
because it's more powerful overall it's
less expensive
it gets newer technology like the navi
graphics architecture
and it has the ram door so you can save
a lot of money by upgrading the ram
yourself
especially for those who want to get 128
gigs of ram
for just 500 on amazon instead of paying
two thousand dollars for it
on the imac pro so there you guys have
it hopefully this comparison video
helped you make a decision and if it did
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe
because we've got a heck of a lot more
imac videos to come very soon
and definitely check out our apple
product merch down below including our
brand new
apple product zip up hoodie so thank you
guys for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
you